many people are excited about socialism
they prefer it to capitalism so it's
time for the new book called the case
against socialism you'd think you
wouldn't have to write a book to make
the case that's what a lot of people
respond they say a case against
socialism wasn't that decided and
Senator Rand Paul wrote the book because
for these people the case obviously
isn't decided don't they know
socialism's track record
Hitler socialism Stalin socialism Mao
socialism you would think people would
have recognized by now Paul's chapter
titles highlight socialism's problems it
leads to corruption it's a boot stamping
on the human face forever because eating
your pets is overrated you would think
that when your economy gets to the point
where people are eating their pets
people might have second thoughts about
what type of economic system they've
chosen maybe eating your pets chapter
points out that Venezuelans have lost
weight because they cannot find food
contrast that with dear leader with
Maduro who's probably gained 50 pounds
we don't know that the dictator gained
50 pounds but he does eat on TV while
his people starve it really sums up
socialism they're still a well-fed top
1% they just happen to be the government
or those who are cronies or friends of
the government American socialists say
we won't be like that when I talk about
democratic socialism I'm not looking at
Venezuela I'm not looking at Cuba I'm
looking at countries like Denmark and
Sweden they all wind up saying with a
kinder gentler socialism that we want is
Scandinavia that's the kind of social
democratic socialism in Scandinavia so
we do a big chunk of the book in there
talking about in Scandinavia Paul's book
is different from other politicians
books Paul did actual research it's not
true that the Scandinavian countries are
socialist while Scandinavia tried
socialist policies years ago they then
turned away from socialism they
privatized industries and repealed
regulations Denmark is far from
socialist plant economy Denmark's Prime
Minister even came to America and
refuted the
Socialists claims pointing out Denmark
is now a successful market economy with
much freedom to pursue your dreams and
live your life
in fact when experts rank economic
freedom Scandinavian countries ranked
near the top of their private property
private stock exchange we learned that
actually bernie is too much of a
socialist for Scandinavia Scandinavia
did keep some socialist policies like
government-run health care the media say
that brings huge benefits it's why
Swedes live longer but this is the trick
of Statistics you can sell well the
Swedes live longer and they have
socialized medicine and yet if you look
hard at the statistics you started way
before socialized medicine 60 years ago
Swedes already lived longer you live
longer likewise the socialist welfare
state didn't reduce poverty
Scandinavia's culture did for me it's
really really important to work
Swedes tend to work hard Paul tells a
story about Nobel prize-winning
economist Milton Friedman the Swedish
economist comes up to him and he says
well you know in Sweden we have we have
no poverty and and Friedman responds any
scenario we have no poverty among
Swedish Americans today Swedes in
America have a much higher standard of
living than Swedes and Sweden Danish
Americans to socialism simply does not
create that magic world of prosperity
plus equality that today's socialists
suggest but the biggest case against it
is that it crushes freedom kissa
socialists get elected by promising
fairness and equality
the only way you can enforce those
things is you have to have an equality
police or a fairness police and
ultimately they show off with truncheon
tanks tear gas and riot police why does
it always lead to a boot stamping on
your face forever if you want complete
socialism you have to take the property
from people hey what up you say what up
you say here's Hugo Chavez doing there
hey what up ESA
the best kind of socialist leader ends
up having to be ruthless because you
can't be a kinder gentler socialist
leader and get the property by contrast
capitalism largely lets individuals make
our own choices it's a direct democracy
everyday you vote either for Walmart or
you vote for Target you vote with your
feet with your wallet and the people who
succeed other people get the most votes
which are dollars and as long as there's
no coercion it seems to me that that
would be the the most just way of
distributing a nation's economy it's
good that Senator Paul's around to tell
his fellow politicians the truth about
socialism it doesn't work it's a recipe
for disaster
look what happens as we approach
socialism around the world it's a
history of famine and genocide Stalin
Hitler Mao Pol Pot Castro Chavez Maduro
it doesn't work